I was like y'all I love doing this show
I really do I didn't even know I would
but I was like I gotta I gotta make a
change for me and like my family Kelly
Clarkson putting Family First Clarity
becomes apparent and priorities become
apparent during a recent appearance on
Talk Shop live the host credits her
loved ones for relocating the Kelly
Clarkson show from Los Angeles to
Manhattan an explanation that comes
after news of the move was confirmed to
E.T earlier this month
[Applause]
what it did point out too is like being
isolated and it's so far from your
family that's not good for anyone and
like my family's East Coast so they're
they're North Carolina base where I feel
like our family like
me and my kids like really needed a
fresh start yeah and it just I could not
get it here and there was just hurdle
after hurdle with things and and I was
like you know what I I was like I gotta
I gotta go east coast now that Kelly
will be based in New York she'll be
about an hour away from her family an
adjustment she tells Topshop live NBC
execs fully supported I am an open book
but at some point I'm a mama bear more
than I am a person in a public eye so I
care 100 more about my children than I
do anything else on this planet the
Kelly Clarkson show will officially
relocate to NBC Studios in Manhattan's
30 Rockefeller Center this fall it's a
dream I didn't know I had yeah and I
mean it turned out to be like such a
dream job like I love it Kelly also
admits moving to the Big Apple gives her
the opportunity to invest in another big
dream also guys I'm in love with like
theater and Broadway and all of that
like and and I never thought I'd get a
chance to um do anything yeah
yeah eventually I would love to do
something I'm in the works of like
um writing something right now writing
something for Broadway or just writing
something else for Broadway yeah like I
I love I love the element like I don't
like acting like in movies and TV but I
do love like stage stuff but while she
has lots to look forward to news of her
transition comes with its own set of
drama and I love my team that I'm
working with here a rolling stone expose
published days after the announcement of
the cross country move included 11
current and former staffers claims of
the Kelly Clarkson show being called a
toxic work environment shortly after
Kelly shared a message on Instagram
writing in part quote I love my team at
the Kelly Clarkson show and to find out
that anyone is feeling unheard and or
disrespected on this show is
unacceptable with the source recently
telling E.T Kelly was completely
shielded by the executive producers from
everything going on at her show and
Kelly has hopes that her new chapter
comes with a fresh start adding in her
Instagram message quote as we prepare
for a move to the east coast I am more
committed than ever to not only ensure
that our team that is moving but also
our new team in New York is comprised of
the best and the kindest in the business
foreign